not too long ago we got news that there
was going to be another Deadpool movie
coming out this December not too much
was really known about the film that is
until about a week ago I'm still doing
my giveaway so if you want a chance to
win a copy of infinity war or ant-man
and the loss on blu-ray some special
edition posters and memorabilia all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero so again about a week ago we
found out that the running title for the
movie is going to be a Deadpool before
Christmas not only did we find out the
title but we actually found out that
this movie is going to be essentially
Deadpool - but rated pg-13 this was good
news for the younger fans who were not
able to see any of the Deadpool movies
due to them being rated R however a lot
of fans didn't really like the idea of
this but there is some potential good
news that comes along with this movie
it's been recently discovered by MCU
cosmic that this movie will include 15
minutes of new footage not seen a
Deadpool 2 which will include new
characters now I say potential good news
because we're not 100% sure what this
means the new character could be Fred
Savage reprising his role from Princess
Bride as we saw in Ryan Reynolds a sweet
so the 15 minutes of new footage could
simply be a Fred savages character or it
could be scenes from Deadpool 2 that are
just altered in a way to make it
acceptable for a pg-13 movie it is very
interesting that they are making
Deadpool into a pg-13 movie and
releasing it when they are the movie
will be coming out with and will have to
compete with bumblebee Mary Poppins
returns Holmes and Watson and spider-man
into the spider verse however I still
hope that the reason they're doing this
is so they can introduce a pg-13 version
of Deadpool into the MCU Disney most
likely will not have a rated R version
of Deadpool in their movies Bob Iger
said that they would consider doing a
rated hour movie but I just don't see a
rated R version of Deadpool appearing in
an Avengers movie which is what I know
we'd all love to see so my fingers are
crossed hoping that
this somehow has to do with moving
Deadpool into the MCU but it looks like
we'll have to wait till December to see
maximum answer in the meantime I will
keep you up to date with everything we
hear regarding the Deadpool before
Christmas let me know your thoughts on
this news of 15 minutes of new footage
and an additional new character don't
forget to subscribe comment and like the
video so you can enter the giveaway and
stay up to date with everything relating
the Deadpool before Christmas and
everything marvel as always thank you so
much for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]